here's a quick story just about another
one of these self-inflicted
embarrassments for the current
administration yesterday you actually
had two press events but both of which I
covered live in the morning you had
Donald Trump's press secretary Kaylee
McKenna nee do a standard press briefing
where she comes out speaks for like 90
seconds 75 seconds or usually relies the
other 15 are just saying hello and then
in the afternoon Donald Trump did his
own press briefing and what was very
interesting was that in the morning the
topic of testing came up and the topic
of Trump not wearing a mask came up and
weirdly when Kay lima kennedy was trying
to defend Trump not wearing a mask in
many situations she said listen Trump's
tested multiple times a day for
coronavirus which is weird and I'll play
that part of this for you first wore
masks in May the president wore a mask
at Walter Reed out of an abundance of
caution but as I've made clear from this
podium the president is the most tested
man in America he's tested more than
anyone multiple times a day and we
believe that he's acting appropriately
the president is tested for coronavirus
multiple times per day that's definitely
odd but okay so then hours later you
knew it was going to happen Donald Trump
was asked earlier your press secretary
said you're tested multiple times per
day for coronavirus can you talk about
how frequently that's happening and
Trump says he looks clearly confused and
he says I can't even think of one time
where I was tested more than once in a
day
usually I'm tested once every two or
three days what was yeah take a look sir
president first I just want to get
clarification your press secretary said
today that you sometimes take more than
one test today why is that how well I
didn't know about more than one I do
take probably on average a test every
two days three days and I don't know if
any time I've taken two tests in one day
but I could see that happening so this
is once again not an issue of
interpretation this is just a very
concrete practical matter Kaley McKenna
he defends Trump's lack of mask-wearing
by saying he's getting tested
times per day now if that were true that
would raise questions of why are most
people waiting five to seven days for
results and Trump's getting multiple
tests with almost immediate results
although I get it he's the president but
the point is we still have a testing
problem in this country if you don't get
your results back for five to seven days
as many people don't you can spread the
disease to multiple people while you're
waiting for your test results and Trump
is barely wearing a mask and getting
multiple tests per day but then Trump
just straight-up says I don't know
anything about multiple tests in a day
I'm tested once every two to three days
so if there is a briefing today I'm sure
Kaylee McKenna nee will be asked about
it I'm sure she'll have some prepared
explanation that may already have
happened by the time you see this or
maybe there will be no press briefing at
all today but as usual caught lying
again and the theme is they go too far
when there's by the eye I don't want to
say this is this is a normal question
everybody's told to wear masks why isn't
Trump wearing one when they see a
hostile question an accusatory question
as far as they are concerned they go
overboard in trying to defend and that's
how you get this why isn't Trump wearing
a mask
oh he's tested all the time he's tested
multiple times a day and there's other
examples of this when Trump says
something racially off-color and then
he's called on it he'll say things like
I am the least racist person ever that
go hold on a sec that's a weird thing to
say maybe just say you're not racist but
the least racist person ever you know
saying I'm not racist it wouldn't be any
more believable quite frankly but it
will it would at least be more plausible
or when asked about testing Trump says
we have the best and the most testing
well no we the best not really the most
no not per capita the fastest results
certainly not when asked about deaths
Trump says we have the lowest mortality
rate well no we don't of course none of
these things are true and it is another
one of these little self-inflicted cuts
that comes from trying to be hyperbolic
and go against anything perceived I mean
they're so trigger Abul they're so
thin-skinned
what would qualify as just a basic
obvious journalistic question in any
other country with a free press here
these are seen as a tax and they
actually generate obvious and provable
lies one of our sponsors today is
hydrant and they are giving my audience
25 percent off your first order this has
been a game changer for me this is a
refreshing electrolyte powder that you
mix directly into your water to
rehydrate your body because it is packed
with the four essential electrolytes
that your body needs the most that's
sodium potassium magnesium and zinc and
because of how hydrant is formulated
it's an efficient way of getting
yourself rehydrated and it tastes
awesome there's a variety of flavors I
have blood orange which I love you can
also get grapefruit and lime a lot of us
don't even realize when we're dehydrated
a lot of the time and it's become a
really great part of my daily routine if
I'm under hydrated I'm affected
physically I'm affected mentally and I
think you never fully understand this
until you use hydrant for the first time
I get a great boost of energy when I'm
properly hydrated if I've been
dehydrated they also have a version with
caffeine which I love if and when that's
what I'm looking for everyone in my
audience gets 25% off your first order
when you go to drink hydrant calm /
Pakman or just enter the code Pakman at
checkout I've put the link right
underneath this video